info
うん
ああああああ
ん
ん壊さないよよすいませんしばだけど明かさずに実家でのんびりしていました集まり髪
だけ話しなきゃクビの毛メッツ切ったんですよ
お前らが持っサーモスター言うから自覚したら変なのにだったんですよ
どうしてくれるんですか
僕ももう月一人暮らしに外れるんでもうちょっとお待ちください
イエスに時商品紹介1回のしなかったやしたしたけどあんまりしなかったから
まぁ最初はこんなもんでいいと思います
とりあえずね
実家なんであんまり声出せないです
テンションもなんかいつもみたいなたんじゃないですか
ほんと家族なんか実家実家の人が youtube やってる人ってすごいなって思い
ますねっ
いつ戻るのペヤングですね
th
はいこんな感じですちょっと振り出てきます湯切りも知ってきました
ばっちりですただこれ低い山の畑目のためだ
大津京付
だめだこの場所駅 the 普通にあげましょう
スプーンくらいです
ヴィセでも特に何も同じねー今なはっきり言うけど
切れずのご飯は満水ん手本に最初に何食べだってや定食食ったんですけどやばかったら
すべてが美味しくて貴方がね恵まれすぎだ
ああ
いやー
普通のペグにポテト放り込んだだけかもしれないです夏が食べてみないと何とも言え
ません
また今じゃない分アーサーそうでもねーよああ
まずあったんで食べてみたいと思います
ん
ございますっ
ます
ん
思っ
ターンにはある
中のペアんぐですね普通のペアだけど普通のペンがおいしいから
まぁ結果的にオーライって感じですポテトやきそばって何だろうね聞いたことないです
よ
元がわからんからなんとも言えん